antenne 2 et philips vous présente le
bar de la plage
l'émission d'été de thierry ardisson
oh
[Musique]
e
le vieux piano de la place le jeu
console aucun solitude vieux pianos la
place à des clients dont l'habitude de
danser
hamdi lé dimanche les autres jours ça
sur les planches
dans la mer qui se souvient il rêve son
feu s'est alors je sens tout court battu
de ma cachette et que soudain de rang
tremblante ému en lui je m'arrête
mais c'était nous voulons tous que je
retourne comme cette musique jali mais
pour me fait du mal
me fais vieux vieux piano bonsoir
bienvenue au bar de la plage avec
premier amour premier baiser mais est ce
que ca poussan bon le sable chaud
entente il toujours siffler le train
voie de garage ou terminus ses chaînes
d'ici dernier épisode de notre galerie
de portraits de sa plage à la page
andré bercoff ivres de livres les
aventures de lolo chez les blaireaux du
bord de l'eau très chaud pour les petits
marie leurs actions de maryse et le
barman qui ne l'ouvrent qu'à bon escient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a chanté les madrilènes qui volent
aux arènes le temps des lots dans lequel
les norvégiennes ont le sang chaud et
bien que les amène qu'est nationalisme
mais on oublie tout
soleil mexico
[Musique]
en dessous
sonnés les maîtres des îles qui vous
empêchent de quitter les bateaux co
c'est d'écouter semaines d'aventuré
mexicaine celle de l'esprit mexico
mexique ont tous un soleil qui changent
tout le temps parler de foot et le
bonheur de chacun des sites au mexique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dont deux femmes sont nouveaux et tu
seras toujours le paradis des carrés de
la mer une aventure mexicaine du soleil
de mexico où ça nous rappelle une
semaine
mais quelle semaine dès qu'elle est chez
nadeau remis sous marins se promène on
dans ce cadre le boléro
deuxièmement cette échelle plus lienne
vous m
on parle au galop on oublie tout
sur le beau ciel de mexico on devient
fou à l'écouté une semaine la vente du
commerce mène le soleil de mexico mexico
mexique
[Musique]
ce soir gagner un baladeur cd philips
répondait en tapant 36 15 codes à 2 à la
question suivante enterrer mon aîné
richard anthony
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un soir jacky bonsoir monsieur qu'est ce
que vous me conseillez ce soir j'active
le péché c'est pas nouveau je connais
monsieur c'est lova moor
c'est bien ce que je disais c'est pas
nouveau c'est peut-être pas nouveau
monsieur mais cet éternel
[Musique]
bon ça on n'est pas double jeu mais je
vais quand même te demander ton vrai nom
c'est comment marie ouais on est disons
que honda jourdain mais quoi ses jambes
à ton père faisait des lova moor sans le
savoir
alors tu es une petite fille en fait ce
qu'on sait pas très bien c'est une
petite fille de la campagne au départ
n'ont pas tout à fait tu vois je suis
une paysanne imagine bien dans les
champs de sarcler les très jeunes des
mines et des haricots
j'ai beaucoup d'agents rabin et 10 mois
alors quand tu étais petit tu aller en
vacances à l'île d'oléron chez la
grand-mère de ta cousine ça se passe et
comment là bas eh bien ça se passe et
c'était des vacances merveilleux
charmante ça a été mais première
suite
la nuit je me souvenais je faisais du
stop chez les discours bah ouais c'est
ça a été les premiers amours c'est vrai
que tu te c'est vrai que tu te coucher à
huit heures du soir que tu dormais
jusqu'à minuit et que tu ressortait à
minuit et à grand mère se trouvait très
reposée finalement qu'est-ce qu'elles
sont sages elle pensait que je dormais
toujours quoi la composent et les
diablesses la nuit alors les amours de
vacances alors les amours de vacances je
crois que j'ai dû échanger mon premier
baiser sur une des plages et je ne
savais pas que d'ouvrir la bouche
matelas l'on évoque la langue
alors je me suis dit mais qu'est ce
qu'il fait c'est bien grâce à son gala à
wayne j'ai trouvé ça c'est dégueulasse
j'ai raconté ça à l'air d'écouter un
garçon gabon car ça m'a dit que c'est
normal la petite fille à faire tu t'y
habitues et qu'une fois je me suis prévu
une habitude va maintenant ouais ça va
et on crie tu sais j'ai une bouche qui
appelle les gg c'est une tromperie dans
dix mois alors bon ça c'est des premiers
baisers profonds mais pour le reste ça
t'est arrivé à quel âge avait alors pour
le rsa battue c'est la campagne on est
très précoce alliage s'attend au pire
alors moi déjà j'allais me planquer dans
l'est
dans les champs pour regarder les plus
grandes à faire leurs premiers ébats
amoureux
et puis moi j'ai dû avoir versé pas vers
12 ans je crois quand même mais quand
même après je suis resté de 12 ans à 20
ans est sage et j'ai recommencé à 20 ans
ah bon non ce n'est pas plus que ses 8
ans on y touche et non un non combat le
mec c'était très mal démerder enfin je
crois un petit aperçu que c'était joli à
quel âge à la très tôt parce que mes
parents me faisait monter sur la table
de la cuisine
alors ce que j'avais pris mon bas et on
faisait danser et j'entendais on disait
qu est ce que la jaune cours cette
petite fille nue nu vers quel âge ça à
moi je devais avoir 6 6 ans ouais sept
ans alors il y avait des escaliers je me
souviens chez moi et j'étais déjà
exhibitionniste je descendais ni les
escaliers et j'attendais mon père et ma
mère on fasse ce genre de réflexion ça
me pose énormément
s'il a pris assez tôt tout ça après tout
très tôt alors pendant qu'ils étaient en
vacances alors les rompre avec des fois
tu es parents venaient et à ce moment là
vous aviez sur la place du village parce
que l'epo quand on regardait pas la télé
j'étais en vacances les gens on va on se
réunissent et sur la place du village il
y avait tous les vieux du village qui
était là et puis vont ils raconté des
histoires incroyables et puis on était
là ricaner bêtement faute et qu'on
allait leur voler des bouteilles de
pineau parce que c'est reynald juno des
cheminots aux gérants et puis on se veut
un petit
voilà c'était sympa c'est là alors tu es
monté à paris très jeune finalement donc
elle a dix ans j'avais fait mes études
pour et éducatrices de cas sociaux et je
devais faire après cette école oui bah
oui j'étais une petite des bleus et tous
ses petits enfants
et puis je suis monté à paris faire un
stage dans une école et au lieu d'aller
à l'école je passais mes nuits dans les
boîtes qu'un jour j'ai rencontré un
chorégraphe qui travaille au crazy horse
et il m'a dit écoute et et que tu es
très doué pour là dedans j'ai donné des
cours gratuits silbande je connais pas
tellement d'argent et pauvres et un soir
il m'a emmené voir le spectacle du crazy
et puis j'étais assez fasciné il m'a dit
tu dois bosser là j'espère juste en
quelle année c'est à peu près à la mode
et les vies si tu ne seras pas alors
voilà je serai pas pauline au système là
pour le coin mais j'étais très jeune
quand même d'être impossible quasi
existait déjà il existait depuis très
longtemps
départs en vacances c'était à saint
tropez à dallas êtes fascinés par le
mythe bardot
mardi c'était quelque chose de commun
avec bardot c'est qu'en fait et comme ça
tu es sculpturale en fait au fond d'une
femme très simple tu as fait tout
gentils nous et moi je suis là la bonne
terrienne
voilà j'ai la tête sur les épaules pieds
sur terre
et oui je suis simple et elle est là
hélas est bien sûr cette grande qualité
un an quand tu fais fasciné par bach l1
jeudi parce que vraiment je trouve
sublime et ce qu'elle fait en ce moment
pour les animaux bon je trouve ça
merveilleux
tu fais quoi toi pour les aliments
importés trois chats écoute mes trois
chats je les aime déjà c'est déjà
beaucoup
et puis tous les tous les chats que je
trouve je les amène chez moi et je les
nourris geler la débrouille toi tu fais
beaucoup de choses pour les cochons qui
sommeille au fond de chaque offre aussi
quand tu fais quoi maintenant je fais
rien je vais je me repose je prends le
soleil jeune âge je m'éclate de temps en
temps avec le rosé ça je dois le dire
j'adore manger j'adore manger j'adore
manger et puis j'adore lance tu fais des
siestes l'été ouais j'ai pas pu le zou
normal crapuleuses c'est quoi qu'est ce
que tu fais pendant l'essai scapulaire
qui baisent le petit buzz
ah oui ça m'est arrivé non généralement
général j'adore j'adore dormir donc je
peux viser en rêvant si tu fais tu fais
la sieste ou chamakh dans un an
oui bah oui c'est bien si tu verras que
j'adore parce que ça te ça te met dans
un dans un demi sommeil parce que tu
sais que si tu bouges trop le hamac eux
mais voilà j'adore peux pas dormir
complètement voilà j'adore comme ça toi
est ce comme sur un nuage du matin grand
fantasme
we dance et sieste comme ça de me
réveiller c'est que tu rêves de faire du
cheval nu oui ç'a toujours été un rêve
pourquoi mais j'ai peur des chevaux de
voir ce que je sais pas je trouve qu'un
cheval c'est bon de toute façon c'est
beau et puis je trouve que la
morphologie de la femme s'adapte
parfaitement toutefois la l'arrière
train de la femme et l'arrière premier
cheval quoi de plus beau c'est vrai en
plus avec de crinière qui flottent au
vent
bon voilà c'est pas très bien images par
messieurs et 10 mois pour à tulle a
jamais fait quand même peur des chevaux
à bon alors je préfère se boucher les
hommes tu vis énormément c'est bernard
d'un kit a initié la lecture qu'est ce
qui t'a fait dire au début comme j'étais
pas très doué en histoire de france
alors il m'a acheté toute la collection
des délits breton c'est bien alors non
ce sont mes livres de chevet tutu
tricote ouais ça je le crois pas tout
alors là tout ce que tu me racontes et
jusque là si tu es sexy
d'un seul coup tu imagines train de
tricoter des achats régime côté
xavier le grand mère je prends mes deux
grandes aiguilles mais je sais pas très
côté je tricote des écharpes de trois
mètres de haut
est ce que ton jules est obligé
d'apporter d'écharpés côté n'as tu me
force pas la portée par exemple dix mois
il ya une question qui me turlupine
c'est quelle expression bernardin oui
quantité est bon il y avait plein de
filles au quasi pourquoi il a choisi toi
peut-être poser la question maintenant à
vivre ça dure en parler quand même tous
les deux ouais parce qu'il m'a il m'a
dit que j'avais un côté un côté enfant
un côté pur
malgré les apparences de diablesse été
fidèles bernard da te fais dire j'ai
passé ma réponse est oui a lancé un oui
pour agacer ou alors mais j'ai peut-être
été fidèle avec mon corps n'est
peut-être que dans ma tête j'ai pas
d'elle c'est mieux que la vertu d'un tel
lot et pas avec d'encore beaucoup qui
n'a pas été fidèle lui paraissait bas il
est tellement tour est jolie fille d une
sacrée contre le mans ce crazy la
concurrence il ya 24 superbe beauté qui
sont renouvelés tous les trois ans elles
sont toujours jeune et belle
donc ouais mais bon tu vois je suis
toujours là toujours présent ma peine et
sa reine alors la différence d'âge entre
vous c'est génial j'aime pas les jeunes
hommes jeunes j'aime les hommes qui
m'apporte intellectuellement pour moi
c'est beaucoup plus important que
on est super jeune c'est facile tu peux
du peuple en a plein axe et à partir de
quel âge on ait sa chance à leurs 30 ans
[Rires]
[Musique]
je connais un qui soit dans ses poumons
et les yeux c'est vrai voilà comment on
fait pour draguer dans votre région
comme moi c'est une drague et comment
vous feriez déjà un peu quand ce parti
twice rafraîchir je sais pas en collant
pas un peu en froid là ouais bah disons
que j'étais bien j'étais parti sur
l'idée quoi avant l'été vous fâchez pas
à la pêche aux femmes ont moins
alors oui t'as réfléchit un peu pour ce
soir là bas malgré tout que je suis
fatigué bassin pour le mondial c'est
vrai oui
qu'est ce qu'on va faire ce soir
tu as envie concrète
pour avoir les idées soumises ce massage
dans le dos j'ai vraiment les massages
des céphalées les massages non pas du
tout non pas du tout ouais mais si tu te
laisses un peu inspiré bon je leur
gilles lefebvre il me semble je vais
essayer de pêcher un poisson problème tu
prends mal cuisine j'ai pas plu du tout
d'avoir ce sera alors
je fais la bonne cuisine bon c'est tout
bon comme j'adore manger c'est vrai os
il va dormir et manger et puis c'est
tout ce que je sais faire
enfin l'amour voilà rana patience ça
toute la nuit il partie de la nuit et le
reste est les résultats je dors oui en
fait tu sais dimanche c'est ton copain
en réalité ces ventes effectives crush
[Musique]
on va dire que méchante
ouais d'accord mais le problème c'est
que tu dois pu dire un quart à lui alors
dire non et comprendra
je vais parler qui troque rester là
dominique franceschi
veux tu veux
rappaz devait passer vraiment fera pâle
face au vent latéral prométhée guette
pas premier servi et premier quart temps
mais non mais non tu vois ça va ça
durait alors oui je vous promets
attaquer mais l'attaqué mais est un bloc
tous un peu le système
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour ce soir
legrand est quand même parce que c'est
des copains depuis longue date au nom
non pas seulement à celui qui me freine
plus belle la plus belle déclaration
d'amour va portera ce soir
alors j'attends c'est déjà un départ
allez je te ferai un petit massage ce
soir où n'importe quoi il va pas être
trop jaloux ton copain je conçois nom
est important pour nous car tous les
deux cas le coeur qui bat depuis les
cinq dernières minutes ce qui va
vraiment plus vite comme on dit chez moi
il va tout le temps 8 a donc taken from
demoiselles de suite
la secte est doux et plus déclaration ah
bon
[Musique]
avec ma levaï est une tradition en ton
pays chantent maritime les femmes pour
garder un corps une peau ferme et
fraîche se roule nu dans la rosée du 1er
mai oui tout à fait je m'appelle sa
toile regardes tu vois ça a marché
face à un marché pareil que bon c'est
une vieille coutume charentaises et vas
y paraît que ça raffermit la peau et en
y réfléchissant je me dis que finalement
c'est peut-être le froid tout ça bien
marché
sabrina et quel est le secret du titien
alors le secret de ce qu'ils ont été
refaits d'avoir non pas du tout jamais
été refaits non non mais bon ça dépend
des époques dans ma vie j'en ai plus ou
moins parce que c'est une femme
lorsqu'elle prend la pilule sa double de
volume et ça alors qu'est ce que je suis
pour mais je prends la broye message
n'est fait car et c'est pas moi c'est
pour ça qu'il reste du rabot il faut il
faut les aimer c'est comme ça encore et
puis je prends je n'ai douche à le
passer tout seul tous les recours à
l'epo ils sont en forme de pub en forme
de poire mon match roy en forme de pomme
alors on voit pas bien parce que les
cheveux
ah oui c'est plutôt pop le crayon ne
soutient pas non non c'est pas de bol
elle fait même pas le test pas encore ça
viendra pompes et les tétons les voient
pas ils sont comment enlever son petit
accent petit puis heureusement parce que
je trouve ça indécent de l'allégro
d'étonnant c'est indécent mais peut-être
que pour un homme c'était trop petit
mais pourquoi est ce que tu es sensible
des tétons way très sensible même si son
petit pont
quels conseils tu donnerais aux femmes
pour garder de beauce un soutien-gorge
travail et ma foi ça qui tombe c'est pas
le bon s'appeler trait aux tic et les
hommes qui adore les sentiments dans un
décolleté maintenant avec les scellés en
voiture vous armature ça remonte tout tu
prends pas soin de nos pilotes n'ont
jamais vraiment été bien être libre
voilà ce que je suis au bout mais
j'imagine que j'aime me balader nu
j'adore sortir levenson columbia le
soleil à vous mais bien méchant pas dit
comment montrer non non je peux toucher
voir la fermeté non
ah ouais
[Musique]
m
mais
[Musique]
et
t
[Musique]
m
à quoi pensez-vous jacky au pluriel
monsieur sans lui pas de complexité donc
pas de vie monsieur vous avez raison
c'est essentiel le riel de train par
exemple sérail équitablement
ah oui pour moi parce qu'un train
déraille
monsieur
[Musique]
quel effet fait je vous attendais tu es
né où je suis né à pourrières
ces hausses à pourrières c'est un
village qui est célèbre par cette
histoire c'est dans la vallée de l'arc
c'est c'est là où a eu lieu la bataille
d'aix en provence qui oppose et marius
empereur romain
quelques 40 ans avant jésus-christ au
serment et auto est maintenant acquise
les thèmes les tétons mais ça c'est moi
d'être au top voyez c'est ça s'appelle
pour rien parce qu'il ya tellement de
morts que c'était l'eau pourrie assez
pour ça et à côté un petit village aussi
qui s'appelle pour sûr et en bronze en
10 pouces il est possible c'est pareil
c'était l'endroit omettez le fumier de
cheval de brebis tout ça donc c'est une
bataille gigantesque gigantesque je suis
né le cul tourner vers le mont aurélien
et la tête d'un à ses deux victoires et
qu'elle soit fait toute ta vie là-bas
pour hier alors je ne suis pas resté là
je vous dirai à l'école qu'est ce que tu
as fait après le lycée alors après je me
suis marié et alors j'ai eu un petit
alors c'était bonnard parce que si c'est
l'époque des cas ne te marier leptine et
c'est au moins neuf mois après au moins
est là bas on avait fait passer ne peut
pas gagner amont et en bohême enfin le
progrès dans la rue et déjà écouter plus
tard ils sont mariés au moi de jouer
toujours en octobre au bout de 4 et 5 en
ligue 1 mais c'est pas possible
wallace est alors après une facture ce
petit sur le dos ce petit comme souvent
et aussi comme cela s'est fait après
je suis rentré dans une banque à y
apporter une casse
il y avait une annonce et il me faisait
ni pourquoi pas ouais
puis ça a marché sur st je suis resté 18
ans c'est là que je suis arrivé au
lavandou ces professionnels à ces
professionnels au départ j'étais
directeur de la banque qui leur est
imputé aux là je te dis pas j'étais le
roi du découvrir c'était sympa avec les
groupes trop alors un la banque
elle ne comprenait pas moi je vais te
dire vous pouvez en avoir 50 ou sant
yann et ça arrivait pas au dixième de ce
qui me reflétant le côté tu comprends
manufrance combien malheureusement
d'autres milliards pour une banque est
elle différente
moi je disais bord notre mieux le
découvrir
même avec 15 min clients c'est pas vrai
ça ne sais pas c'était moins cher que la
ciotat est alors donc t'as fait ça et
après tu t'es arrêter de travailler
non qu'est ce que tu as fait oui je me
moque eut commis de plancher occupants
d'une maison de vacances
alors qu'est ce que tu fais de ta vie
alors j'essayais de
de perdre le moins de temps possible
parce que bord dans le midi c'est dur
ouais ouais je vais avoir du mal là
quand même
non c'était 7 c'est une déconner
d'entendre ça je vois je te dis parce
que honey honey juger à travers une
culture pagnolesque avant on nous juge
sur les a priori qui sommes fous par
exemple par exemple la partie de cartes
de pagnol ouais il ya un cocu un kart
figuraient et là il ya déjà une erreur
si elle n'avait que 1 progresse de cocu
ça serait quand même un gros malheureux
ça fait 25 ans en voilà premièrement
deuxième main les tricheurs ouais à nice
et qui samba et quitter la table parce
que c'est harry triche ça n'existe pas
c'est pas avant non
les provençaux sont pas comme ça non
d'abord on ne triche pas aux cartes
un riche beaucoup de choses mais pas au
cas par cas
ça c'est la deuxième ris tout tout tout
l'oeuvre de pagnol nous classe
si tu veux part aux yeux de la france
entière
si tu ne vois c'est vrai tu vas à la
paix s non pourquoi je tourne le dos à
la mer je sais pas ce que je sais pas
nager d'abord un peur de mourir
et puis bon c'est
jamais été attiré par le bronzage ni par
la mer ni blanc sera la chasse j'y
allais oui j'y allais mais j'ai eu un
gros malheur j'ai perdu ma chienne et ça
m'a fait de la peine que j'hérite
surtout pour elle et puis je suis plus
ça fait de la dren ça a été un des plus
grands chagrins et avis un certainement
mais qu'est ce que tu fais alors on dort
c'est bien je m'occupe de deux des
jeunes qui a eu la bonne idée de choisir
moneta mm pour passer avec elle mais en
dehors de ça si j'ai une vie un peu je
suis
je fais pas de politique je suis adjoint
au maire au lavage nous a quand même
ouais c'est pas de la politique c'est la
panique mais les permis de construire
c'est toi qui les donnent moi je suis à
jones pour avoir je ne sais pas
responsable de ce qui se passe là je
veux pas dire que désolidarise de ce qui
se fait mais bon j'en donnerai - les
permis de construire toi
doit-on pas moins mais j'en donnerai je
serai peut-être un peu plus regardants
sur la qualité de diffusion 2d même
débit
dis moi tu vois qu'elle est mort sa
provence est malade mais n'est pas morte
[Musique]
à quoi pensez-vous jacquet lagarde skis
vareilles cieux c'est le rapport
mais la vie ne tient qu'à un fil
monsieur il faut tirer tirer est encore
tirée
vous êtes triste jacky
trouvez que c'est qu'est monsieur
d'avoir habité pendant 18 ans en face de
la gare d'estivareilles sans jamais
avoir entendu un train sifflé
[Musique]
borloo
nous quitter
ce sens
oh
d'accord
[Musique]
mais
aussi
[Musique]
c'est vrai
que c'est triste
ici plein
à
je
g
tout seul
abandon
sur le thé
[Musique]
les eaux
des gens
tu veux
et j'entends
c'est elle
que sept
[Musique]
soit
là j'ai failli
[Musique]
c'est à peine
je
[Musique]
c
on va
que c'est loin
[Musique]
auras-tu
jamais
euros
m
[Musique]
c'est qu'il valait
et
[Musique]
mais je sens
comment
les gens
aussi
pas
et j'entends
c'est le
j'entendrai
si peu
c'est toute ma vie
[Musique]
j'entends
la richard anthony bonsoir alors
j'entends siffler le train
c'était en quelle année 62 62 et qui a
écrit cette chanson paroles et les
musiques la chanson c'était un folklore
américain qui était écrit deux cents ans
plus tôt deux cents ans plus tôt que je
te jure way et il a retrouvé comment
parce que t'es qui toi tu écouté
beaucoup la radio américaine la nuit
danser ça non mais tu veux que je vous
raconte ça va être très longue gc a
brisé mon grand père était diplomate
anglais en egypte là où je suis né alors
donc j'étais vert l'anglo saxonne
soutenait et tout ce qui est américain
anglais je connaissais par coeur et ce
fonds pourrait rester dans ma tête
pendant des années des cerises et puis
un jour d'itt
quelle belle chanson il faut la faire en
français et c'est comme ça que cette
partie je demandais à mon ami jacques
plan de faire des plans parce que
j'étais pas cap de les faire moi même
c'est comme ça qu'on a sorti premier
tube de l'été en 1962 murat vert et
contre tous
la maison de disques et vas y on dit pas
question monsieur de choisir une chanson
lente pour l'été et cgt j'entends
siffler le train donc un peu l'inventeur
du show de l'été en quelque sorte
est ce que tu sais combien ça rapporte
et j'entends siffler le train le fils
qui s'est attaqué aux jeunes écopent sa
wii u ce don qui tiennent mieux tu es
content que toi si tu es heureusement
qu'ils sont la règle comme ça tu sais ce
que tu as gagné on croirait ont des
copains on est au diapason
je me suis pas tiré j'ai payé 1 evo10
richard à partir de maintenant il faut
être sérieux
ils savent ça je dis ok d'accord et donc
à ce moment là on est copains mais tu
disais quoi avant de chanter les
origines de ta famille alors que ton
père était ambassadeur de rembrandt au
grand père était ambassadeur
d'angleterre en egypte c'est ça c'est là
où tu es né au caire en quelle année en
1938 c'est bien internet
oui parce que je le savais je vais le
synchroniser la vérité non mais je 54
beurre et canton de vaud
jeudi j'ai 56 ans la testa fait donc ton
père était fait son grand père était
ambassadeur sa famille toi tu étais
élevé là bas non dans du coton vous êtes
venu vivre à paris après être parti en
argentine à peu vous êtes revenu à paris
c'est très compliqué tout ça c'est vrai
le pari et j'adore la france tout d'un
coup que je découvre pour la première
fois qu'on valait 1 janson de sailly et
mon père au bout de deux ans il me dit
on par milan en italie
je dis non je reste en france et je
continue mes études en france c'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est toi tu as fait du
droit
et puis ton père tu as pris une
garçonnière dans pertes assez bien la
gare solaire et titouan pour pour toi
vous pouvant est alors ton père te paye
la garçonnière et toi pour pour quand
même subsister à hâter moyens je vendais
fric voilà tu deviens vrp au
réfrigérateur courageux avec une voiture
du sport comme vous savez quoi comme
voiture une austin il à bravo ça se
passe et comment laver préservateur mais
tu sais comment on faisait après dîner
on avait dans le 3è 4è arrondissement où
il y avait tous ces chers amis d'afrique
du nord qui débarque et s'était pas
plaint c'était fin des années 50 et on
mettait des prospectus dans les boîtes
aux lettres dans la nuit tu vois en
disant je passe demain tu vois comme ça
je serais pas jeter il s'était déjà
prévenu que j'allais venir lors essayer
de leur vendre navarro ouais non c'est
pas mal mais c'est d'essayer de faire ce
qu'il faut faire et ce que je dis alors
un jour quand même parce que l'histoire
est drôle un jour tu il ya un type et je
vais vous expliquer qui d'ailleurs qui
te dis mais si tu veux gagner de
l'argent il ya un truc que tu devrais
essayer quand même c'est le rock'n'roll
j'ai une famille absolument ultra
puissante à travers le monde et ils
m'ont dit grâce à ton père nous avons
tous réussis alors nous sommes tous là
derrière toi pour te faire continuer tes
études
tu dois pas fini tu finis la faculté de
droit j'avais passé mon bac grand mère
et fils aux agents sont en faisant vide
est d'ailleurs une fois comme c'était la
mode à cette époque là et ensuite bon on
m'a dit on va m'aider j'ai dit ben non
je voulais le faire tout seul et ils
m'ont dit quoi je dis je sais pas et à
mois plus tard j'ai dit j'ai trouvé le
filon parce qu'il fallait que je
devienne aussi riche que du route du
jour au lendemain mais c'était pas une
question de tonio c'est une question de
réussite le standing de parakou rapport
au reste à faire les wave rider et je
leur ai dit j'ai trouvé alors ils m'ont
dit qu'est ce que c'est jeudi j'ai une
idée fabuleuse
il ya des musiques américaines de
paulhan caire des platters des délices
pressé tous et cetera qui marchent
fabuleusement bien comme je suis anglo
saxons la wii et que j'aime bien ce
genre de musée mais que je suis français
maintenant je trouve qu'en france il
faudrait chanter ça en français et j'ai
une idée
il ya une époque où certains à porter
des jeans d'autres importer des formules
de magazines toi tu as apporté des
chansons et usa traduit effectivement
comme tu avais une bonne voie ça
marchait assez rapidement quand ils
devenus c'est à dire j'avais promis avec
jean genet est arrivé en 60 alors dit
moi ça c'était avant et après alors
qu'est ce que tu as fait après quand ça
a commencé a moins bien marché qu'est ce
que tu as fait qu'est-ce que tu avoues
jean n'a jamais moins bien marché mais
j'explique cette chose là pour les
téléspectateurs qui vous écoute tout le
monde a le droit d'avoir sa
dimanche où les jours de fêtes pour
prendre des infos nous jamais surtout
quand on fait tout tout seul et je me
suis dit il faut que je suis parti à
saint paul de vence
mais je pensais y rester pendant trois
ou quatre mois finalement j'y suis resté
quatre ans mais j'ai rien fait ouais
mais j'étais en train de récupérer tous
ses week-ends et tout séjour de vacances
que j'avais jamais vu parce que quand
les gens sont en vacances
excusez moi du terme l'artiste nuit
travail
en quelle année le fisc a commencé à
s'intéresser à toi 69 74 ans je me
repose moi je pensais partir six mois
mais pendant cette période là je me suis
enfin permis de dire j'avais commencé à
travailler à 18 ans j'avais plus de 30
ans à cette époque là je ne suis payé
une rolls excusez moi du peu
à cette époque là elle comptait 12
briques tu prends pas 150 que vaut
aujourd'hui donc j'allais droit de la
voir je me suis payé une maison à saint
paul de vence qui comptait exactement le
dixième jeu ça peut péter aujourd'hui
j'étais en plus voisins avec yves
montand et simone signoret qui était la
colombe qui était juste au dessus et
c'était une vieille jument très vieux
jeu suivi un peu tous les trois ensemble
on n'arrêtait pas regarde et bon pendant
cette période là j'ai fait ce qu'on
appelle fiscalement et grâce à tonton ça
n'existe plus parce qu'il est c'est un
cas humain vaut mieux qu'on puisse dire
on m'a taxé par le prédécesseur que je
ne nommerai pas on m'a taxé des éléments
de train de zing la rolls la maison
machin et cetera
alors donc vous devez déclarer ce que
vous dépensez ça c'est le système
français à fond et tout le monde le sait
du mois
à ce moment-là bon bah moi j'ai vécu
pendant quatre ans tu sais à l'aise
breizh en oc port sans peur qu'un jour
ça allait nous tomber sur la tête
j'étais en train de 4 claqué simplement
quelques économies parce que j'avais
laissé tout mon fric à mon ex femme
parce que c'est ma façon de faire mais
alors qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont fait payer
le fisc c'est le gendarme delà de la
localité où j'habitais là copains il m'a
dit
richer nous avons une petite histoire
entre nous que c'est quand vous voulez
mais sans rien me dire
alors je dis je peux il faut que je
viens tour sinon non non non vous n'est
qu'on voulait alors je dis ok d'accord
je pensais que c'était une contenance du
moins pas comme ça que ce soit son père
alors quinze jours plus tard je
téléphone au colonel jarry du verre qui
était utile et je lui dis que la neige
je pars en moto j'ai fait un tour en
moto je mets mon plus beau jogging et je
suis en train de faire du sport en moto
parce que j'adore la photo mais est-ce
que je peux passer toute la nar alors il
me dit me faisais quand vous voulez
j'arrive à 16h30 et je m'assois redisons
bond de quoi s'agit-il
l'histoire la petite histoire il me dit
c'est pas une petite sophie desaulle
essayez-vous c'est grave je dis qu'ils
de quoi s'agit-il
il me dit vous devez 1 million 500 mille
francs d'arriérés au fisc français
et si vous ne donnez pas un chèque
certifié dans la demi-heure qui suit tu
parles c'est au 30 les banques fermées
dans la gare d'arras et sans vie d'un
expert chez objet
ah bon toi et c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et c'est tout c'est là qu'ils
étaient en vie en prison
oui et alors c'était comment la prison
parmi eux alors dis-moi bons problèmes
avec le fisc
et puis aussi problème faut bien le dire
pour les pensions alimentaires que t'as
pas vraiment toujours bien payés rubis
sur l'ongle m'adore c'est un peu ne sont
jamais remariée elles sont superbes mais
des journées des raisons des goûts de
luxe pt1t femme n'aurait fait ne m'en
voulez pas savez vous le savez vous avez
eu des savons et vous les avez toujours
des gens fantasment jeunes et nos mre
peuple sa frappe à ta cazin et elles ont
toujours eu tout ce qu'il fallait
moi j'en que des enfants c'est ça qui
est important n'est pas ce qu'ils
s'adorent entre eux et 10 alors maman
arrêtez de vous coltiner mais à noël
dernier je te jure c'était peut-être
voilà au jour 2 voilà mais il faut le
dire noël 91
tout le monde s'est retrouvé donc lé les
droits tv les quatre femmes et 11 ans
pourquoi
ouais grâce à mes enfants on a passé une
messe de minuit
ex 3 us ensemble alors entre le premier
plein avec trois femmes et ma petite
amie
huit enfants ce qui est normal
on passe pas si tu veux dans la
clandestinité où l'horreur en face
d'heure parce que moi j'aurais voulu
garder dans la vie qu'une seule femme
d'avoir simplement trois ou quatre
enfants mais le métier est un métier tu
aurais qui fait en sorte qu'on ait
toujours séparés et moi je n'étais pas
fait pour me marier quatre fois moi je
voulais garder une femme bah oui une
femme il a fait une très belle chanson
là dessus en plus amoureux de ma famille
se sent comment mais laquelle
j'ai du mal à chaque fois en dix mois
pour en revenir à ta carrière tu là
c'est drôle tu me fais parler c'est
drôle c'est drôle comment pour en
revenir à ta carrière tu l'as vécu
comment ce changement de situation c'est
à dire le le passage quand même c'était
une grosse cruz date puis dans ce coup
bombe était devenu héros je suis pas
encore une grosse
tu l'as vécu comment ce changement de
situation on s'en fout c'est pas les
objets matériels
je vais pas te coucher avec une ferrari
ce sera quoi vrai mais si tu là devant
la porte ça fait plaisir a dit mme
richard maintenant tu dis à cannes tu
vis de quoi exactement
j'ai huit musiciens qui sont rares peur
et on n'arrête pas de faire des galas à
tuffé des galas samedi dernier nous
avons fait 3000 personnes à châteauroux
du fait des gars là tu fais des concerts
tout va bien c'est ton seul problème
tellement cet emploi quand même je peux
servir maigrir 1ers jours à cause de ça
j'ai le premier problème cardiaque il ya
une douzaine d'années
est ce que j'ai fait la cordée ayant
joui quelqu'un à los angeles qui m'a dit
qu'ils étaient médecins chefs des pitas
los angeles
il m'a dit richard tu continues comme ça
tu vas mourir alors laisse toi aller
alors le corps tu vois tout d'un coup et
c'est comment on s'occupe plus de moi on
me fait plus maigrir ont fait plus de
télésanté rappeler qu'hier et il a
grossi comme ça et si je me suis fait
pousser une barbe c'est pour le
doublement temps le triplement toi c'est
comme pavarotti quoi c'est parce que
j'ai vu pas voir parce que je la donne
avec la jeunesse qu'est ce qu'il est
beau et que ça va mais moins cette année
j'ai décidé qu est la femme la neige de
rendez-vous si tu le bruit c'est à dire
parce que j'ai envie de jouer au tennis
et faire du ski nautique et tout ce que
j'ai fait avant je me suis juré que
petit à petit parce que j'ai trouvé
vraiment des gens formidables je vais
perdre 20 kilos d'ici la fin de l'année
et en plus j'ai pas long de le dire
l'inclure faire une liposuccion tu
devrais pour enlever tout le gras qui va
pour nourrir parce que quand on fait
partie de ce métier devant le public on
aime
duquel on dépend je pense qu'il faut
être présentable
[Musique]
il est propre nom mais les profs il est
propre au regard des juges avaient
traîné là ça mais vous avez une traînée
c'est bon à l'arrière je vérifie lille
merci les pneus chez toi un petit check
up to c voire un couche tout c'est quoi
cette [ __ ] regard foule des bouleaux
ce que je vais faire un coup à la riaj
sera plus tranquille 1
deux balles ouais deux balles pour le
pare brise sont déconner j'ai plus de
pognon basse paul attendant les
essuie-glaces et [ __ ] de balle je le
crois pas 1 2 53 seroyal démerde-toi en
tornado balle je vais finir parce que
j'ai une conscience moi voilà c'est
gratuit c'est gratuit tu m'entends
gratuit je ne manque de rien c'est ça la
beauté de l'âme à ses cinq balles deux
personnes vous êtes car en tout cas de
s'emballe
rien que des sales wiimote un petit coup
sur le trop voilà les 240 de francs pour
régler ce que j'ai fermé ma caisse des
sous mauricette ouvre je sais que tu es
là mauricette je sais que tu es là vous
mettre un petit coup c'est pour moi
c'est la maison qui offre c'est moi qui
régale ça fait plaisir ça me fait
plaisir
voilà c'est mieux il est d'accord
oh là là là ça vu comme un i phone
voilà c'est dangereux 1
je préfère les changera plus tranquille
mais pour 400 francs c'est pas méchant
d'accord voici monsieur 50 centimes ça
peut être vous manque et 60 centimes
pendant la la j'ai peur théorie non mais
parce que ben non
battant robert attend quand il joue
robert hop un bas blanc beur
on sera mieux comme ça aulas l'a arrêté
a dit tiens c'est le voilà voilà
c'est plus tranquille comme ça merci
monsieur aumont ressembler à mon frère
et son portrait tout craché
impossible de savoir de quelle langue il
s'agit dit quel pays ils viennent mais
en tout cas ça nous permet de nous
frotter avec nos copines sur les pistes
de danse
un bon point pour canards
[Musique]
ces marocains
m
[Musique]
semaine
tél
[Musique]
moi pas
là
[Musique]
m
kelly
il demandé
quel ego
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
en forme jacques est une forme de coin
ce soit comment êtes vous arrivé là
jacky dit - jacky j'me trompe où il
pleut les deux yeux vous tromper et il
pleut qu'est-ce que vous avez c'est soir
jacky je trouve bien un sol en velours
et monsieur car je pars et vous avez
coup de l'autre côté du bar monsieur
[Musique]
alors même qu'on voit danser le long des
golfes clairs a des reflets d'argent la
mer etc
thébaux qu'en même temps on atteint on
va un peu parler de livres politiques
politique attention on va pas parler de
mythes erreur de l'état de rocard
agissent car c'est pas salé
on va essayer un peu de réfléchir parce
que c'est si tu t'occupes pas un peu de
politique c'est la politique qui
s'occupe de toi alors il vaut mieux
peut-être prévenir sa de livre vient de
paraître très intéressante une reddition
et nouveauté la reddition c'est le
protocole des sages de sion la
fabrication d'un mythe par norman cohn
demande qu'on avait écrit un livre
remarquable sur les cavaliers de
l'apocalypse et ses puces et ce faux
fabriqué à la fin du 19e siècle par la
police tsariste pour justifier les
programmes anti juif et c'était quoi
c'était qu' il y avait un livre qui
expliqué qu'ils avaient une conspiration
et que les juifs avaient tout organisé
pour prendre le monde etc etc
et il faut savoir que se livrent donc
qui a été reconnu comme un faux qui est
évidemment un espèce de délire construit
pour des motifs très précis a été
réutilisé par les nazis pour le trouve
encore aujourd'hui dans sap les
librairies du moyen orient et que la
théorie de la conspiration
là c'est les juifs mais ça pourrait être
autre chose marche à tous les coups
il faut faire attention à ça tu vois
quand quelqu'un devient raciste ou
totalitaires ou autre et 10 mais
attendez moi j'ai le droit c'est mon
opinion il faut pas oublier que c'est
pas une opinion c'est une passion ou à
l'irrationnel
or on discute pas avec la passion
irrationnelle n'y a pas de discussions
c'est pas une opinion audi moi je suis
d'accord moi je suis de gauche moi je
suis de droit ça n'a rien à voir on dit
attention ce qui m'arrive c'est la faute
aux juifs aux arabes aux français aux
chrétiens aux [ __ ] et aude et apparaît
ce moment là tu bâtis sur des prémisses
complètement folle un univers qui se
tient complètement à partir du moment où
tu fais un délire et le livre de norman
cohn et passionnant et vraiment je
conseille à tout le monde de le lire
parce que il raconte comment tu peux
fabriquer non seulement un mythe mais
une machine à massacrer parce que
c'était pas seulement
de la littérature c'est la littérature
qui tue et je crois qu'il faut faire
quand même attention à la littérature
qui tu vois j'ai pas pour la censure
mais je suis pour l'explication donc ce
livre il faut vraiment le lire et le
méditer norman cohn la fabrication d'un
mythe
le protocole des sages de sion et
l'autre livre cette année qui vient de
paraître de raoul vaneigem imagine que
staline soit quelque part paradis ou en
enfer n'en sais rien et écrivent une
lettre à ses enfants réconcilier de
l'est de l'ouest
c'est du moins le scénario qu'a imaginé
raoul vaneigem du sénat m le
situationniste l'un des rares théoricien
de mai 68 qui avait écrit le fameux
traité de savoir vivre à l'usagé des
jeunes générations
là il vient de commettre un petit
bouquin absolument délicieux où staline
regarde ce qui se passe et voir le
communisme dissous dans l'alcool du mur
de berlin il voit les bosniaques les
arrêts gobbini les tatars les airs et
les moldova lac et tera en train de
cette triple jeu joyeusement et 10 mai -
je comprends pas vous étaient tous
contre moi mais regarder car le
couvercle de la marmite s'en va on vous
êtes tous là vous étriper en fait dit il
dylan et game bien sûr pas la parole à
présent parler staline illizi mais en
fait le capitalisme d'état qu'on
appelait communisme
qui n'a jamais été du communisme ah ben
c'est fini il dit le capitalisme
archaïque vous vous êtes foutus à
l'ouest avec vos dettes etc
donc il faut trouver autre chose et moi
je vous dise que c'est moi joseph
djougachvili staline massacreur invétéré
et ben les graphes ans il faut vous
reconvertir à l'écologie parce que
demain la grande théorie du siècle ce
sera l'écologie et il prend si tu veux à
travers ce langage dictateur du petit
père des peuples
un formidable analyse des mutations de
notre temps on en a marre du dé gulli
littéraire de gens qui se disent
écrivain et qui savent même pas aligner
trois mots sans dire merde q combien etc
eh bien il faut écrire un français du
xviiie siècle parfait raul venez gamme
c'est écrire ce français classique
et puis quand staline parle dans un
français du 20ème siècle
je t'assure que c'est complètement
succulent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était le bar de la plage salut bande
de nazes rendez vous la semaine
prochaine avec la compil numéro 2 de
double jeu j'appuie sur le starter et
voici que je quitte la terre j'irai
peut-être au paradis mais dans un train
dans les tapis et si je meurs demain
[Musique]
c'est que tel était mon cas montée
blanche jay carney
et quand je sens son chemin
les trépidations de ma machine il monte
des désirs d'un grain de meyrin demandé
aujourd'hui ce qui est positif c'est
fait maintenant préservatif
il faut que tu penses leucate plus chaud
en cours de tango nié ces
ils ont effet de l'apec mois il faut la
leaf lecture est il faut que tu penses
le capuchon coup de temps de nyon je me
sens groupe philips bar de la plage la
question d'état en quelle année aîné
richard anthony et la réponse 1138
vous avez gagné le baladeur cd phillips
à télécommande programmation possible
jusqu'à 20 plages bravo voilà
on attend ça c'est
on a tellement
chacun de notre côté
[Musique]
que voilà
c'est fini trouve à notre rocher petits
titres perdre
pas trop cool et de temps sous tendineux
c'est fini
[Musique]
oh
va pas dire au revoir comme sur la quête
je
si seulement bonjour
alors
voilà
aujourd'hui
un seul mois
j'aimais
peut-être après demain je te retourne
[Musique]
car c'est unis
[Applaudissements]
il se dit
[Musique]
antenne 2 et philips vous ont présenté
le bar de la plage l'émission d'été 2-1
à dix ans et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous
émettez un pouce bleus